hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Jane second Kevin McGuire andrew
pearson here to look back at the biggest
stories of the last seven days would
have been your top stories oh I think
it's got to be the walkout by prison
officers who are scared for their lives
in dangerously overcrowded prisons
Andrew I absolutely loved the fact Nigel
Farage turned the political world upside
down again and got him first to see
Donald Trump in Trump Tower fantastic
story well Donald Trump is our top
stories has been his first full week as
president-elect and many of his allies
glidden Nigel Farage have been visiting
Trump Towers he begins to assemble his
transition team the first foreign
politician in the golden lift was
japan's Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a ana
Thomas Peters reports Trump Tower fifth
avenue new york for now the unlikely
center of the political universe here
amid tight security the president-elect
conducted his first in-person meeting
with a foreign leader japan's Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe a was anxious to
hear Trump's views on trade and security
issues vital to his country but called
into question during Trump's nationalist
campaign but as with many things related
to donald trump the event defied
convention this meeting happened without
any formal contact or briefing between
Trump steam and the expert set the
Department of State or the department of
defense in part that's because his
transition team parading before cameras
and tourists in the opulent lobby of
Trump Tower are concerned with other
things scrambling to put together the
next administration
former New York Mayor Rudy Giuliani and
others including members of trust family
and reportedly former presidential
candidate Mitt Romney are all being
considered for top jobs prompting
reports of a brutal chaotic process and
so the endless negotiations and meetings
continue Trump knows decisions must be
made soon will be leader of the free
world in just over nine weeks well we
mentioned Nigel Farage and of course he
became close to mr. Trump after breaks
it and was quick off the mark to pose
with the new president but he's been
snubbed by number ten as a potential
go-between or advisor with the u.s. I'm
Kevin to you first that we were starting
to get a feel perhaps what Donald Trump
presidency might be like who might be in
his top team yeah what do you think I
think chaotic and nasty isn't it and his
family are playing a huge role which i
think is going to be big problems down
the down the line but I loved them
posing in the before there was gold
indoors or he has he's daughter sitting
in a meeting with the Japanese Prime
Minister this is going to be chaotic
absolutely chaotic and not necessarily
good for the USA all the rest of the
world and what I'm Nigel Farage she was
quick off the mark wasn't he was in my
purse astok I got a whole hour with him
yeah the Japanese president or prime is
had got about ten minutes and he was in
his private apartment which is opulent
is an understatement Wow oh this is
another word a lot of guy you're against
Ali fuels Havelock yeah gall to me
nothing Arab act is amongst me know
who's with her with Nigel Farage in that
meeting said that the door to the lift
was more expensive than his house it is
about five million with so and I think
Theresa May is missing opportunity here
because of course you wouldn't give
Nigel drive an official role but I would
want someone to have a word with him
because he spent an hour with a present
elect that nobody in the British
administration has done and I'd want to
know what he's got to say one of the
things that the the the Donald Trump are
said is slightly road back on a balma
care that he said he was gonna be was
going to repeal that was it that was one
of the big things he has in his first
big interview slightly brought back on
that he has on taken away health care
from 20-odd million Americans will see
what he does he's also his great wall
now
might be a fence did that give you any
heart that it might not be quite as hard
line right wing is uthia it does a
little but you cannot take back so much
of what he said the big bigotry the
racism the prejudice the fact he's being
a sexual predator condemned himself and
his own words on on tape do you cannot
roll back all that so it's not time to
get out the bunting okay before we leave
American politics let's just quickly
talk briefly about Hillary Clinton she
back in front of the cameras this week
very different what does she look like
well she was wearing a lot of people
said she wasn't wearing any makeup I
think she was she just wasn't wearing
quite as much as she had been she
clearly could her own makeup its face to
getting in the professionals who made
her up every day she was on the campaign
trail shattered shattered exhausted
emotional listen to watch a ok now i
will admit coming here tonight wasn't
the easiest thing for me there have been
a few times this past week when all I
wanted to do is just to curl up with a
good book or our dogs and never leave
the house again ok have any sympathy for
her to laugh she lost she lost tough she
said they should never have chosen that
woman because how could the Democrats
not a beat Donald Trump the most
unprofessional candidate ever she was a
disaster the daletech thoughts I'd for
I'd I told I preferred the Marine Bernie
Sanders what even worse what but I think
people were like like her for being
honest it's a crushing defeat and she's
come out and she's admitted it instead
of just trying to brush it with an ego
you pick on you really pick on how
sometimes to how she lives a bit of
sexism there because let's face it
there's no oil painting himself I talk
about those people of a certain age okay
right that is our top news story
American politics in a busy Newsweek so
here are five things that you might have
missed while Barack Obama has made his
last trip to Europe as president he
traveled to Athens to see the Greek
Prime Minister Alexis tsipras as well as
visiting Berlin to hold his final talks
with the German Chancellor Angela Merkel
President Obama has urged his successor
to stand up to Russia if the country
doesn't uphold American
valleys we've already talked about you
Kip but they've been under fire again
this week after an audit leak to Sky
News revealed the party apparently miss
spent almost half a million euros of
European funding the money was allegedly
used to target key constituencies in the
general election and helped boost its
brexit campaign which is a breach of EU
spending rules new Kip has denied the
claims let's take across the Wales where
hurricane force winds caused absolute
chaos across West Wales gusts of up to
94 miles an hour created what witnesses
have described as a freak tornado which
tore through aberystwyth ripping up
caravans no one was hurt but police are
warning drivers to be careful because of
the large amounts of debris on the roads
fIFA has open disciplinary cases against
England and Scotland after their teams
wore armbands bearing the poppy FIFA
forbids players from wearing anything
that can be perceived as political
statement both teams defied the ruling
for the world cup qualifier match on
Armistice Day time now for our gaap of
the week and it is related to football
this week it's Wade Rudy finding himself
on the newspaper front pages off mid Sun
at 5am I wasn't staying on the back
pages in the sports sections as when
photos emerged a thick nerd captain
looking a little worse for wear after a
big night out the FA are said to be
implementing a curfew and booze ban four
players whilst on international duty
ever Kevin dude this is fair that he's
facing this criticism I mean he was he
was off duty he's had a big night it had
a good result but he has a sportsman an
athlete is supposed to look after
yourself he drinks he smokes his diet is
said to be poor no yeah well it will it
is in decline he's only in the england
scored on past reputation i think he's a
mug is the captain has to set an example
and it's a shocking example look you
just shrek is me just a boy I understand
it you know and honestly they should
just sit the clock now you've got
another game coming out you know they
had fun horning five in the morning
boozed up not a good look for the
England team I'm afraid and they won
that game but they probably won't win
the next one don't forget to send us
your nominations for gap of the week for
next week using the hashtag W in our now
it's been a big week for brexit a memo
and good number ten after it claimed the
government still have no strategy for
the UK to leave the EU and the Foreign
Secretary Boris Johnson got into a row
with the Italians over
prosecco our political editor feisal
Islam and I senior political
correspondent Jason Farrell both have
more the government does have a brexit
plan the Irish government published one
last month the Japanese government
revealed its plan the month before as of
yet no great detail from our own
government but today some insights from
consultants who had been inside number
10 working on brexit planning a report
from Deloitte suggest the cabinet is
split on its strategy for leaving the EU
it says more than 500 brexit related
projects have been set up above the
civil service capacity and as many as
30,000 new civil servants will be needed
to meet the workload this infuriated
number 10 who said the report had no
credence and was done by a firm touting
for government contracts
Prosecco and chips that's what the
brexit debate boiled down to with Boris
Johnson warning an italian minister that
if Italy blocked a favorable brexit deal
that could impact on their sales of
Prosecco to the UK Italian Economic
Development Minister Carlo Kalenda
didn't appreciate the comment he told
Bloomberg TV he basically said I don't
want free movement of people but I want
the single market I said no way he said
you'll sell less Prosecco I said okay
you'll sell less fish and chips but i'll
sell less Prosecco to one country and
you'll sell less to 27 countries putting
things on this level is a bit insulting
Theresa May refuses to be drawn on her
negotiating strategy but we know she
believes Britain voted to control its
borders and to leave the European Court
of Justice and she wants the best
possible trading relationship but the
Foreign Secretary has been told he can't
have his fish and chips and eat them
let's talk about Boris Johnson first of
all I mean is this now lay laying bare
some of the issues that they're all
going to be with Europe we fundamentally
costars of it doesn't it look the Prime
Minister is quite clear a red line is
free movement of people she wants to end
it I think that's what the British
people voted for in huge numbers are on
referendum day and it's interesting that
this week we saw the first Creek
tectonic plate shifting Angela Merkel's
signaling in Germany then may have to be
some compromise on free movement now
whether that's because of broccoli or
because she's worried about her own
elections next year with our immigration
policy which is an electoral disaster
for that she's losing every region
election going so I think that the the
it shifting Britain's way you're wrong
you're wrong about Merkel she said
Freeman was still a principle but it's
about what benefits you can claim else
away from saying no it won't be me I
want something which a tree but she gave
it's a dream it's an aspiration I she
gave Cameron some ground on that before
the referendum which Cameron lost but
the Fez went out at Boris Johnson long
ago he's more like a steel slops of beer
isn't he and he lost he lost that
argument and this has come to the high
the government has an old brexit plan
now it's not surprising because it's so
difficult never said that during the the
can't pay for the referent but still
difficult
is a contradiction between saying you
want to be in the free free market and
you want to limit migration and that is
somehow the circle that has to be
squared and no one knows how to do it
and most importantly of all teresa me
doesn't know brexit means brexit means
what she doesn't know we had this report
out this week from Deloitte basically
saying that the government got egg on
all of these thousands of people and
report has to be treated with a very
large degree of skepticism because as at
the time said it was commissioned by the
Cabinet Office if it wasn't it wasn't
commissioned by anybody in government
navin govern you anything about that
report it was a fishing expedition by a
gloater consultants who want a load of
business what do they know about what's
going yet caught a flavour of the chaos
that is there we know there are
divisions you know the right divisions
between ministers and I'll you off and
you also know lie also know they're
having to hire lots of civil servants to
sort out this mess you never put it on
the side of the bus thirty thousand
extra civil servants instead it was 350
million a week for the NHS effectively
which will never happen time for a quick
quiz quiz the week can you tell me who
won the Glamour magazine's Woman of the
Year award and why it was controversial
no I'm just not sure don't home we'll
find out after the break
welcome back to week in review with me
Jade second and joined by Kevin McGuire
associate editor of The Daily Mirror and
Andrew Pierce consultant editor of The
Daily Mail now before the break we asked
who won Glamour magazine's at Woman of
the Year award and why was a
controversial you don't know me either I
tell him if I tell him Carter Allen bono
whoa yeah here's a thief a bloke I'm he
became the first man win the woman of
the year accolade that's the memory
address then he wasn't no the magazine
is in said he was chosen for campaigning
on women's rights promoting gender
equality leading the charity poverty is
sexist at bedok thanked his supporters
by reading out some of their online
comments let's have a listen what I know
how ridiculous is for for me to be on
this stage accepting this award but if I
didn't know how ridiculous it was I did
have the Blessed Internet to remind me
out of all the women alive hashtag Bono
is my favorite it's just so inspiring
how she overcame the adversity of being
a millionaire white dude or it's it's so
important that our daughters understand
that they can grow up to be bono and he
obviously embraced it in the spirit with
which lots of people will have received
it's a for PR stunt did you have before
why can't they there are not enough
women in the world who deserved that
award it's pitiful he's also our world
in his private jet they're doing all
this great work for the third world and
he's teased amitabha taxing someone like
holland AG lap glamorous undermined its
own awards for a bit of cheap publicity
that's why they gave it to him do not
think it is because of his campaign work
this done you know saw what the t-shirts
last year with men wearing them saying
this is what a feminist looks like yeah
that's great in it I me that's all what
you got a few t-shirts so deeply
offensive to women yeah all those
campaigning women all around the world I
they're not its own brief at Britain's
Got its second woman Prime Minister in
history might have been possible commit
and possibly let's move on to the next
story which is crisis week in Britain's
the Justice Secretary is forced to admit
serious issues within the system
thousands of prison officers walked out
of a health and safety concerns and it
came after violence breakouts and
understaffing have continued to plague
the country's jails mark white reports
talk to these officers outside Lewis
prison in east sussex and they'll tell
you the prison service is in meltdown
the record levels of violence have
forced them and colleagues across the
country into industrial action they know
is illegal this category B jail is
typical of many understaffed and full to
capacity just a fortnight ago prisoners
here smashed up a wing causing hundreds
of thousands of pounds worth of damage
as news reached these officers that the
government had won its high court
injunction they were read a letter from
the prison governor demanding they
return to duty but here and elsewhere
most officers decided they were staying
out until the end of their 24-hour
protest action condemned by the Justice
Secretary in the Commons we've already
taken a number of measures to improve
security and safety but unlawful
industrial action is not the way of
improving the situation prisons will be
back working as normal but officers see
normal is unacceptable levels of
overcrowding violence and staff
shortages and they can't rule out
further action in the weeks ahead Kevin
do you think they should have got gone
out on strike it's not a strike a strike
as a legal the prison officers it was a
walkout yeah no absolutely when you're
going to work and you're fearing for
your life in dangerous overcrowded
prisons officers have had this throat
slit been taken hostage and it I think
it's ridiculous actually that they don't
have a legal right to strike the no
point the injustice secretary Liz truss
standing there and in answer as illegal
these people are afraid for their lives
and she and her predecessors cut the
numbers and england wales from what was
it 7,000 they got rid detriment off from
25,000 she's taken on to 9,000 more in
the future but she's left them
dangerously understaffed
the government is taking assets isn't it
Andrew but you know a lot of people will
say including the prison officers and
the Howard leak are being a reform that
what they're doing is not going to solve
the situation now these are all steps
that will improve the situation yeah the
trouble is person spent too much time in
prison cells they're locked up often 23
hours a day which is outrageous and
often prisons are universities to crime
they let they become more criminalized
in prison and they should be given they
should be working or educated every day
thanks 75% of prisoners are in numeral
illiterate but we've also got this
problem in our prisons the front page of
The Daily Mail this week my newspaper
fantastic photograph of the meeting
steak fish and chips how do you get fish
and chips in a prison all on their
mobile phones there's massive abuse
going on drugs are being flown in by
drones it's out of control and often is
with the connivance of the Britain
offices well no the fact is there's not
enough prison officers so you know it
cannot conniving it cannot run a deal
properly with too few staff and it's it
an example of where austerity by the
government has just gone badly badly
wrong and you can complain about things
being smuggled into prisons but unless
you got prison officers to do the checks
it's going to happen right let's move on
to our paper stories of the week andorra
start with you this week and this is a
14 year old girl who has been
cryogenically frozen after death first
time this has happened it scared me I
find this profoundly shocking it's it's
eerie it's Frankenstein science this
little girl was terminally ill she
wanted a chance to come back to life I'm
afraid you can't have a chance to come
back to life if you die that's it I mean
I'm a Christian I believe wasn't a Jesus
may come back from the dead but we don't
come back from the dead she's been
indulged of course the parents what the
parents were divided the grandparents
are paid for it and they wanted to give
us some hope I which I sort of get
before she died but this isn't the
answer and apart from anything else the
cells can often be damaged in the
freezing and so they're almost certainly
weapons to bring her back alive they
said she might bring her back in 200
years well who's going to be around for
in 200 years nobody well might be
completely different you read her letter
and she is a fourteen-year-old girl
dying of cancer and it's absolutely
heartbreaking and if it helped her
passing eases her passing then I
understand it
but it does sound like an expensive scam
nearly 40,000 pounds you might be able
to preserve the physical body but your
memory your thought to all those
electrics they'll have all gone on I'm
sure I just probably sent em now stuck
in a freezer in the United States yeah
horrible is that yeah but you know she
would have surely been cremated or
buried otherwise a box in the ground
it's also for the people here it doesn't
bring them closer either Kevin your
choice now the word of the year has been
announced it's actually two words for
hyphenated what is it post truth
ridiculous some academics have come up
with is how often do you use expression
post truce yeah I've never heard anyone
use it other than academics well we've
been using in relationship trouble I
mean the definition is circumstances
where facts are less influential in
shaping public opinion that appeals to
emotional and personal belief so the
fact that a lot of stuff that person
Trump said in his campaigns yeah wasn't
Alison true but it appealed to somebody
on an emotional level yeah it's just
it's just called spin and and and lies
yeah and phipps and and so why we have
to dress it all it post truth I mean if
you think about the referendum campaign
he'll go banging on about how much you
save on that board and I remind people
that the Treasury said in May if we
voted to leave unemployment would go by
half a million before the end of the
year it's just fallen to a 10-year low
actually unemployment so I suppose that
would quote those two were fall into the
category of post trivia but I just say
episode a spin and hogwash right Kevin
your final paper choice this is about
the latest scandal they're saying to hit
the former top gear presenter Jeremy
calls yeah the old can really had a bit
of a whoo-ha ran an airport yeah the old
motor mouth Jeremy Clarkson in Stuttgart
where he accused somebody would let him
on a flight because he was later being
an Argentinian when in fact he was
Spanish it seems he was also upset
because he'd been given a chicken wrap
for his tea or get it yeah and it is
it's a classic classic case remember the
BBC got shot of him because of a violent
racist assault on somebody and he's up
to his own games if you want ports truth
it is Jeremy close cynically we're on it
say that the venue program about this
all is great
that's me it's being streamed this
weekend he's this soon just forget it
it's playing to the stereotype of Jeremy
Clarkson who's a boorish bore who throws
his weight around and people loved him
for people right for a pop very popular
and it's a great how the program it was
the biggest online campaign wasn't it
I've never watch that programme my life
so don't understand cars all him he's
hugely popular man he's in reverse gear
now he's not a capture what are you used
to big at Dulce we'll see I wouldn't
write him off yet right time through ups
and downs I was starting with you Kevin
a you are sending up this week angler
Myrtle she had a the last meeting who is
always yes she's away it was right
around where you've got no glass man
yeah there we are she is hosting a mini
summit in Germany Theresa May's gone
over Barrack Obama's gone over and
Barack Obama said that he was America's
biggest ally in Europe it's not being
your mate David Cameron that special
relationship is what any point when she
knew the election enter our locals
attacker are towering political sir are
we are able trouser suits we're sending
her up [ __ ] shaving down Black Friday
that's right next weekend it is which
magazine found it's really a con
something like half forty-nine percent
of goods you could buy cheap up before
or after so what do you think you're
getting a bargain you might just very
good generator so I which magazine
blackstreet your flat screen tell you
might be a lot cheaper me before yeah
and it lasts for a week now doesn't a
lot of retailers are making it
stretching it out about him Marisa
bending it down anti-consumerism right
Andrew you are sending up this week
Meghan Markle so this is the girlfriend
of Prince Harry who suddenly she's a big
star in America and Canada so that's
film if she made and called antisocial
is being read eated so when she made the
cutting room floor before she's going to
be MARAC see re edited into the film and
they're going to remark at the film
cashing in on her relationship a poster
I think she like a prince harry so
touched by her or an expression a food
phrase that Prince re so keen on there
it's gonna pay for her bodyguard daddy
on there actually she can't afford to
give him the elbow now can't she is a
meal ticket ok we're sending her up
I think she's quite wealthy in a road
right Kevin we are sending down though
this week Andrew something that Bob
Dylan he's not going to collect his
Nobel award it was stupid to give him
the Nobel Prize of it too anyway because
actually yes he's a musician and he's
too busy to go and collect it well don't
bother give me a tournament giving his
privates Apollo was a bomber 75 you said
he has a prior engagement should we just
respect that no it's rude and surely is
he's not sick it's a great honor good
come gather round people we're usually
never lost him in the first place you
know okay so show some medals yeah okay
right we're sending you down mr. Dillon
sorry about that don't do send us your
nominations ups and downs using the
hashtag w in our well thank you very
much for joining us for our review of
the week we'll be back with much more
next week but for now it's goodbye from
them goodbye and it's goodbye from me
goodbye